that's such a good time we had a blast  in England this year it certainly seemed  like it he guys all seem to like each  other and get along great  yeah we're not just kidding around we  genuinely adore one another's company  yeah I mean it's kind of overwhelming  but I mean I really enjoy the whole  promotion part of things you know and  and this year we got to do some  fundraising for a cause that we really  believe in and then meet the person who  won the the lottery for that and that  feels really good for Julia's house this  omae's fundraiser we did so it's all  fairly manageable I am fascinated with  Eastern culture and Korea was where John  and I went on the first Ironman and they  welcomed us so warmly and now obviously  forget the fact that they're massive  Marcus I just love being able to visit  there so I'm gonna go up a ball without  you okay forget some good stuff okay  some good stuff  you